Fiat presents the 500l the 1960
cinquecento revisited this baby is a
retro style design conceived for long
trips the original 500 played the same
rule in Italy as the beetle did in
Germany says our reviewer mantas the
compact car that mobilised the masses in
2007 the Italians remembered what a
pretty card was and decided to relaunch
it back in the 60s the L version stood
for luxury today it means March but
actually the new 500 L is more a Fiat
Punto Montes is going to put it through
its paces and see what it can do fast
echoes the clarinet arena Alice can the
design is a winner the round forms are
pleasing to the eye and like various
chrome trim details paid tribute to the
old Fiat 500
from the outside it looks like the 500l
has lots of trunk space
it holds 400 litres but a German
Shepherd would hardly have enough space
for a nice ride but it will hold plenty
of potatoes bags and bags of them the
seats can be folded down in two ways
producing 1310 liters of cargo space
enough for 5000 spuds montes takes the
500l onto a country road where it cuts a
good figure
the suspension provides a good feeling
for the road without being uncomfortable
the steering is a bit soft with a slack
response but it's a safe and secure ride
nonetheless
montes likes the front field of vision
and the addition of windows in front of
the door the back window is narrow
making it hard to judge where the car
ends when in Reverse all too often the
500 ELLs interior has lots of pleasing
vintage style details little design
touches can be found everywhere the
sat-nav is mounted on the dashboard
montes would have preferred it
integrated into the stereo system the
radio provides good sound the Lounge
versions interior is extra stylish the
back seats even have tree tables for
longer trips the seats are comfortable
but too short taller folk will find
their legs hanging in the air even
montes not so big has 10 unsupported
centimetres of leg with it's 88
kilowatts of power the Fiat 500l is not
a powerhouse but it can zip along nicely
for the top speed of 183 kilometers an
hour the 1.6 liter diesel version
consumes 4.8 liters of fuel per 100
kilometers not bad at all long trips
aren't unnecessarily expensive the
lounge edition with the big diesel
engine costs 22,000 150 euros
yeah I'm Martha says the engine doesn't
feel at home at low revs around 1500 per
minute it starts to work better at about
1800 revs and then it moves forward well
the lounge version also has a panoramic
glass roof bat and the large windows
mean the interior is flooding with light
and also provide the passengers with a
good view
mantas really likes the panorama roof
and the incredible feeling for space it
gives the Fiat 500l so the 500l has more
to offer than good looks our tester
summary the Fiat 500l s driving
qualities are convincing and the price
is acceptable but to be honest it
doesn't have much in common with the
real Fiat 500 apart from some design
elements families will be interested to
hear that the Fiat 500l also comes in a
7 seat version with a third row of seats